كشف المستشار الالماني النقابه عن اول
استراتيجيه للامن القومي في تاريخ البلاد
الحديث مضيفا انها ليست وسيله بلغايه يجب
على جميع مفاصل الدوله المشاركه فيها
اضافه ان المهمه المركزيه للدوله هي ضمان
امن مواطنيها بدون تنازلات بدورها قالت
وزيره خارجيه الالمانيه انلينا بيلبوك ان
العالم يشهد تماما في تعدد الاقطاب
والتنافس اضاف التابر بوك ان روسيا تشكل
اكبر تهديد لاوروبا ولحلف شمال الاطلسي في
المستقبل المنظور كما اوضحت ان الصين تشكل
ضغطا متزايدا على الاستقرار الاقليمي
وكشفت عن انشاء وكاله فيدراليه للتصدي
للهجمات السيبرانيه الخطيره
ينضم الينا من برلين مراسل جزيره عيسى طيب
عيسى
عناوين هذه الاستراتيجيه الجديده ابرز ما
جاء فيها وكيف تختلف عن سرقاتها
نعم في داهيه تختلف بالضبط عن مما كان
يسمى بالكتاب الابيض الكتاب الابيض كان
عباره عن ورقه توجيهيه لسياسه الدفاعيه
لالمانيا لكن هذه الاستراتيجيه هي خروج من
عباءه الورقه البيضاء او الكتاب الابيض
وهو ينسجم مع اعلان المانيا
طلاقها من سياسه المحافظه وتغيير عقيده
العسكريه بعد الخطاب الشهري المستشارت في
اليوم الثالث من بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
نرجع الى الاستراتيجيه الاستراتيجيه لها
عناوين متعدده لكنها تعكس في صميم واحد
وهو ان المانيا اقرت بانها ستتصرف كقائد
للامن الاوروبي هذا كان واضح في النقاط
الرئيسيه خصوصا عندما تحدث المستشار عن
وتحدثت الوثيقه عن بحث ضمانات الامنيه
لاوكرانيا ما بعد الحرب وحاليا الامر
الاخر وهو تاكيد تصدي المانيا عسكريا من
خلال دعم اوكرانيا كما قال المستشفى في
المؤتمر الصحفي الى ان تحقق غاياتها
وبانها مستعده ان تواصل ذلك في الامر
الاخر الذي يؤكد بانها المانيا خرجت من
رقعه الحيض الضيق الذي كان مرسوم لها ما
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه هو توجهها
الان الى الصين الصين كان عنوانا بارزا في
الوثيقه وعنوان بارزه في المؤتمر الصحفي
يمكن تقسيمه الى تفصيلات سريعه اولا الصين
تستخدمون النفوذها الاقتصادي من اجل تحقيق
غايات سياسيه الامر الثاني بان الصين تعمد
الى تغيير القواعد التي يقوم عليها النظام
الدولي ثالثا بان الصين تستعذره تستعرض
عضلاتها من اجل الهيمنه الاقليميه
والدوليه الصين كما قالت الوثيقه وكما قال
المستشار وكما قال المتحدثون بان وجدنا
لغه للتخاطب معها لكن ينبغي ان نناقش معها
القضايا الامنيه والقضايا الاخرى نتحدث عن
الصين وبعد ايام قلائل تبدا المشاورات
الصينيه الالمانيه والتي يشارك فيها وزراء
الدولتين وايضا المستشار والرئيس الصيني
ايضا تحدثت عن الصين عن مساله حقوق
الانسان بانها الصين تسعى الى انتهاك حقوق
الانسان بانها تقوض مفاهيم القيم الغربيه
وقال بان لا يجب علينا الا نسم في تراجع
النمو الاقتصاديه ان نسمح للصين في النمو
الاقتصادي لان الصين ضروريه لحل كثير من
المشاكل في العالم وايضا هذا يتقاسم مع ما
قاله المستشار سابقا بان بان لغه التفاهم
كانت ناجحه مع الصين خصوصا في اجتماع
مجموعه السبع القضايا الاخرى وهي قضيه
الحلق الشراكه مع الاطلسي اكد عليها مرارا
وقال بان هويه السياسه الامنيه لالمانيا
لها مرتكزات منها الصداقه العسكريه
والسياسيه مع فرنسا ايضا مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نعم